[Applause]
these people believe they represent the
majority view in this country which they
say is disgusted by the far-right
policies of the alternative for Germany
or IFD they accuse it of wanting to
deport migrants who've become
naturalized as Germans the party
leadership denies that but these
demonstrators are not convinced it just
became uh neutralized recently and these
people are planning to take home from me
I'm German Iranian I came to Germany
around 8 years ago and I have already
lost a home to fascists I don't want to
lose a second one the wave of mass
protests was provoked by word of a
meeting held at this building in potam
in November where leading members of the
ifda and other prominent right- Wingers
are reported to have discussed the
deportation policy known in German as
remig a policy lawyers say is
unconstitutional and which many people
associate with Nazism one analyst told
me why the protesters use the phrase
never again is now at the demos never
again now is decisive for the people
because 80% says we don't want to have
national socialism and they they feel
that they are sincere in their Endeavor
to correct this democracy to destroy
this democracy to make a racist state
with all the problems and Civil War
they they Pro they think they will have
it and this is the reason why they are
so why this never again now is so that
phrase was also used in parliament
against the RDA last week prompting this
angry response from its joint
leader never again is now must also mean
not having State compliant media houses
being set up as a secret service to be
used against us the
opposition we're not nervous those who
are above all are the social Democrats
because in the state elections in
Eastern Germany this summer voters there
will make them pay and I'm looking
forward to
that the rfda is particularly strong in
the old East Germany but demonstrations
like these do seem to be having an
effect at the national level in early
January the party was polling around 23
24% now that's dropped to around
19% but that still means as many as 10
million Germans support the RFD Dominic
Kane alzer
Berlin make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
alzer